o menino boa tarde eu vou falar sobre
inovação na cultura de doação no brasil
um pouco do que eu tenho aprendido nos
últimos três anos de trabalho na área
social a 10 anos e nessa última semana o
brasil tem um privilégio de falar sobre
esse tema hoje sendo que no último mês
é a gente viveu uma coisa que foi
inédita no mundo
acho que devem ter visto mais de 3
milhões de pessoas postaram um vídeo
jogando um balde de água gelada em suas
cabeças em prol de uma causa que nem
todo mundo conhece é e doando recursos
para organizações que trabalham com ela
com essa causa que é inclusive a doença
chama-se ela esse desafio me
impressionou muito porque era uma coisa
muito simples e que se viabilizou
rapidamente todo mundo de alguma forma
ou participou foi afetado ficou sabendo
mas mais do que isso me impressionou
toda força que gerou em termos de
resultado
a gente teve mais de dez vezes o valor
doado no ano passado por essa causa em
menos de um mês
em comparação os estados em risco com o
dia de hoje então assim seja está
falando de uma doação que aumentou em
dez vezes era de 3 milhões de dólares
para mais de 35 milhões
a gente está falando de uma doação que
realmente teve muito impacto em outro
aspecto que me impressionou foi uma
coisa global é que realmente pegou todos
os países mesmo agente que a organização
que criou essa essa
os pesquisadores que criaram esse
movimento foram eram americanos e chegou
em todos os lugares
a grande pergunta que isso me trouxe foi
como é que a gente faz uma campanha
pontual uma doação os pontual virar uma
coisa cotidiana que realmente pode ir a
vários lugares
bom é nesses últimos dez anos eu tenho
trabalhado muito com vários várias
pessoas e ouvido muitas histórias sobre
quem quer transformar o mundo
empresários empreendedores sociais em
todos os lugares eles eu quero
compartilhar com vocês duas dessas
histórias tão pra começar eu queria
contar a história de um casal que eu
conhecia os três meses
eles têm uma escola que eles criaram há
mais ou menos 15 anos que era pra filha
deles se que disponibilizaram
as crianças do bairro né isso acabou
virando uma organização que hoje atende
mais de 100 crianças em uma região bem
isolada
eu posso imaginar o desafio que esse
casal teve pra captar recursos de
começar esse projeto então eles devem
ter tido 500 reuniões com a prefeitura é
muito burocráticas fechar uma parceria e
conseguiram recursos que não cumprem
todo o valor que custa escola e aí eles
captaram recursos como amigos né fizeram
realmente uma vaquinha e agora estão
querendo expandir a aumentar o prédio e
pra fazer isso eles vão ter que lidar
com todos os desafios dos investidores
privados que também são vários
as histórias são sempre muito parecidas
os empreendedores sociais têm um sonho
que é desse tamanho e emprego investidor
sobre vado o público pode ou quer
investir só um pouquinho
muitas vezes porque realmente as
demandas são muitas e um recurso
limitado mas eu também acho que tem uma
perspectiva nova surgindo que é como é
que a gente faz isso tem impacto e não
ser só canalizado por recurso público o
investimento privado de empresas não é
bom
60% do tempo dos investidores sociais é
gasto com captação de recursos segundo a
ashoka mackenzie um estudo que eles
fizeram recentemente em alguns anos mas
que é superinteressante 60% do tempo
deles focado só em captação tem alguma
coisa muito errada e porque o talento
desse empreendedor não necessariamente é
o talento da captação é tem talento para
outras coisas para atuar na base nela e
ele gasta muito tempo fazendo isso eu
nunca vi o empresário gastar 60 por
cento do seu tempo
captando recursos para sua empresa eu
acho que quando está acontecendo tem
alguma coisa errada em geral quando o
negócio está indo bem a gente tem o que
fundos bancos por pessoas procurando o
empresário para investir no negócio dele
ao estado que eu quero contar de um
amigo que a empresária jovem e ele me
desafiou uma pergunta muito boa falou
assim eu quero que cada real meu doado
têm o maior impacto social possível
eu falei bom futebol
vou pensar que eu vou ter que ficar
comparando a organização falando a essa
organização aqui tem um impacto maior
como é que eu faço isso quando uma ong
trabalha numa área de saúde e outro de
educação é super difícil né
são contextos diferentes são histórias
diferentes
então quando a gente é isso tudo me leva
a pensar recentemente que sim eficácia
da doação é muito importante a eficácia
do seu investimento social também é
muito importante ela está sempre
presente na conversa com os empresários
os empresários estão preocupados e todos
os doadores estão preocupados em geral
quem vai do ic é procurado para doha tem
pouco tempo muita demanda é tá muito
preocupado com o lucro da empresa o
desafio operacional que é apresentações
objetivas e claras mas também é visto
como alguém que só pode doar dinheiro
isso não é verdade
o talento do empresário nesses não é
necessariamente se o empresário
competente tem muito a contribuir para o
setor social
há alguns anos a gente vem vendo vários
empresários entrando nessa área ajudando
na área de gestão etc
além dos empresários empreendedores
sociais
a gente tem alguns estudos apontam que o
brasileiro quer doar não sabe como o
brasil tá no ranking global de
solidariedade na posição 72
mesmo sendo uma das maiores potências
econômicas em algo muito ela tem um gap
muito grande
é um salto muito grande nisso como é que
a gente faz para diminuir esse salto é
em 2011
eu comecei a trabalhar com cláudio
fucking a convite de um empresário
empreendedor social que chama-se ariva
enfim é pra realmente repensar esse
modelo de cultura de doação ea partir
daí comece a me aprofundar em porquê
porque a gente doa tão pouco no brasil
existem vários motivos e um estudo da
mckinsey aponta é mais de sete razões eu
vou falar de algumas delas
o primeiro motivo pra gente do ar pouco
é porque a gente tem pouco mecanismo se
você quer do auge é muito difícil e tem
que entrar no site da ong vez ela serve
a ninguém fala sério
se você conseguir doar pelo site é
incrível mas não necessariamente você
consegue
e aí você doa e não necessariamente você
recebe a informação do que foi feito com
o dinheiro que leva a gente para o
segundo desafio que a transparência como
é feita a gestão deste recurso ea
transferência dele com os seus doadores
então os jogadores muitas vezes não são
fidelizados
a gente acaba doando quando no brasil
quando são campanhas pontuais como o
criança esperança ou aquelas
organizações muito grande que conseguem
te mandar um boleto em casa
é assim que a gente acaba normalmente
como pessoa física fazendo a doação
o terceiro problema além da
transparência é democratizar o acesso a
gente tem sempre as mesmas pessoas
doando para os mesmos lugares
a gente precisa começar a fazer de uma
forma que as pessoas todas possam doar
então é esses três desafios juntos
trazem muitas possibilidades de 2011
para cá várias iniciativas surgiram ea
gente vem acompanhando algumas delas
algumas delas eu vou contar algumas
histórias
a primeira delas é o portal juntos ponto
com ponto vez e não sei se vocês
conhecem o portal de crowdfunding que as
ongs podem entrar se cadastrar em
escrever um projeto para que as pessoas
doem envia via site uma ferramenta que
tem funcionado bastante eles arrecadaram
mais de um milhão por organizações
sociais
é um número razoável própria esse começo
de operação e estão crescendo muito
segundo iniciativa brilhante assim que é
bem recente chama-se quero bem é um
aplicativo para celular que você comprou
alguma coisa no restaurante em qualquer
lugar tira uma foto da sua nota fiscal e
você doa nota fiscal paulista para onde
está cadastrada então é uma coisa super
simples e fácil de fazer e você pode
escolher um geek estiver cadastrada no
aplicativo
o terceiro é um portal atados
alguns de vocês é voluntário aqui que do
o tempo está crescendo voluntariado no
brasil é o atentado é um site super
bacana pra quem quer ser voluntário as
ongs cadastro tudo o que elas querem em
termos de talentos e as pessoas se
inscrevem para isso é e e podem ser
voluntárias essas homens
então a gente tem e por último e super
importante
gente assim uma irmã iniciativa que eu
adoro chamado e mais do e melhor é um
site que estimula as pessoas a contarem
suas histórias de doação porque elas
doam isso acaba empolgando mais gente a
doar
então é de lá pra cá surgiram muitas
coisas a gente no na negativa que eu
faço parte em 2011 é começou a trabalhar
um pouco com essas perguntas que a gente
pode criar para realmente amarrar todas
as pontas e criar uma solução boa para a
ong que tem tanta dificuldade em
captação boa para o empresário que quer
participar e quer participar com o
melhor e também boa pra quem quer doar
e foi assim que nasceu o arredondar que
o movimento social do varejo como a
idéia super simples quando você chega
numa loja no supermercado e uma farmácia
um restaurante que fizer parte do
movimento
você pode arredondar para cima os
centavos da sua compra
e essa micro doação fato organizações
que são selecionadas e monitorados
continuamente pela equipe do arredondar
a gente a equipe só pra isso
então a gente garante que a doação vai
chegar no lugar certo que vai ser bem
aplicada essa idéia parece super simples
e é esse o nosso desafio nos últimos
três anos foi transformar esse conceito
em simplicidade operacional
nós ficamos um ano e desenvolvimento
tributário bastante desenvolvimento de
tecnologia e pra fazer com que isto é
totalmente seguro e ligado e
transparente entre todos os sistemas da
loja da retaguarda do repasse a gente
contou com inúmeras parcerias então
arredondar junta o que o varejista pode
oferecer porque ele abre o canal de
venda a gente capacita equipe dele eu
vou falar um pouco só sobre isso daqui a
pouco é é super importante o
envolvimento da equipe a gente muda o
sistema da loja gente habilita a função
de arredondar a gente já tem que ter uma
parceria com o sistema então é o sistema
da loja já dou o tempo dele para mudar o
sistema para que ele possa arredondar
então a gente realmente virou um
botãozinho né
nesse sistema da onu
quando se vai fazer a compra de um
sistema ela que tem um botãozinho
arredondar e é isso que possibilita que
as que as empresas a redonda ea gente
também procura organizações neves fez um
edital público em 2012
fizemos uma seleção aberta organizações
laicas a partidárias obviamente idôneas
super sérias e comprometidas com o
impacto que elas querem gerar é e aí
nesse movimento a gente acabou criando
um mecanismo supersimples e que tem
engajado muitos clientes das marcas e
possibilitando que o varejo oferece um
serviço novo para seus clientes que é o
serviço realmente a pessoa poder fazer
uma doação de uma forma transparente e
segura e rápida
alguns de vocês já jazz já arredondou é
e é bom as doações são até de até 99
centavos a gente a gente começou a
operação em escala em março deste ano
depois de ter feito um projeto piloto de
dois anos com uma rede parceira em duas
desculpas de um em duas lojas a gente
ficou um ano inteiro operando só em duas
lojas pra minimizar todas as coisas e
foi muito interessante primeiro porque a
gente aprendeu que quem doa primeiro é
quem abre o seu canal de venda
este empresário tem que estar engajado
tem que tá afim ele faz toda a diferença
quando ele faz isso
segundo é que a gente teve 70% de adesão
70% dos clientes que entraram na loja
nesse período arredondaram foi um número
muito alto que mostrou pra gente que
isso tem força e quando a gente decidiu
expandir o projeto né expandiu
arredondar a gente a gente contou com
muito apoio então a gente buscou
parceiros
a gente hoje tem mais de trinta investir
é doadores que ajudaram a gente a se
estruturar mais de 30 empresas que
apóiam a gente um dia a dia no
funcionamento de tecnologia a
comunicação e inúmeras empresas que
estão interessadas em entrar no
movimento de março até agosto que é
quando começou essa operação piloto em
março
a gente teve 75 mil doadores sendo que a
metade deles foi no último mês
nós estamos com
sandro operar em escala estamos com 15
marcas arredondando é e eram só três no
começo do ano então a gente está em
plena expansão
o que isso tem mostrado é que é super
possível fazer uma coisa simples e muito
impactante dá certo no brasil desde que
a gente esteja focado ea gente tenha
tempo para investir na inovação e na
estrutura que isso exige
por último para encerrar eu gostaria de
dizer que tem um grupo de iniciativas
que se juntaram pra fazer um movimento
pela cultura de doação e é tem sido
super legal a gente está trazendo para o
brasil é o gui 20 uso e que é o dia d do
ar aqui que a gente está chamando que é
terça feira dia 2 de dezembro vai ser
esse ano que vai ser um momento em que
tanto as marcas como as pessoas podem
criar ações para fazerem com que as
doações de fato funcione e ea gente tem
percebido que trabalhar com a
consciência com a cultura da doação
começa um trabalho individual
corpo-a-corpo sim então eu espero muito
que eu acho que a gente vai conseguir
resultado a gente vai conseguir juntos
né
eu acredito muito que esse poder da
multidão de todo mundo junto é capaz de
alavancar as doações que a gente tem no
brasil colocar o brasil num outro lugar
em termos de impacto social é inclusive
superar os números do balde de gelo
por último queria compartilhar com vocês
o nosso vídeo nem do rei do mar que
inclusive foi 100% doado por todo mundo
que participou disse
esse é a pergunta que muda o mundo
grandes homens e mulheres na nossa
história se fizeram essa pergunta se a
terra não fosse chato e se o tempo fosse
relativo e se todos tivessem direitos
iguais àqueles centavos que sobram das
nossas compras todos os dias
pudessem fazer uma grande diferença
foi essa pergunta que a gente fez e
assim nasceu o movimento a resultar
a idéia é simples mas é muito boa
na hora de pagar as suas contas você
pode arredondar os centavos clássico
e todos e se sentavam juntos podem virar
milhões que vão para as organizações
sociais que trabalham pelos objetivos da
onu causas como acabar com a fome ea
miséria melhorar a educação preservar o
meio ambiente
as organizações são selecionadas
criteriosamente e acompanhadas bem de
pertinho garantindo o bom uso da sua
doação
nossa tecnologia simples de usar fizemos
parcerias com várias empresas e criamos
um processo rápido e transparente
agora você só precisa chegar no caixa e
dizer 'sim eu quero arredondar minha
compra porque todo mundo quer doar
só faltava um jeitinho redondinho de
fazer isso nossa expectativa no ano que
vem é alcançar mais de 10 milhões de
doadores e eu conto com o apoio de vocês
pra gente fazer isso obrigada